hmm
is an example of a sound but as mundane
as that sound might sound on its own the
process that it takes for that sound to
get from myself to yourself is more
complicated than you might think
fortunately however it's not complicated
enough to stop me from trying to explain
to you the whole process through the
medium of song in this week's episode of
fun science fun science fun science is a
science of fun yeah ready it starts with
an idea or an impulse to make a sound
and then a message gets sent from my
head to where my vocal chords are found
and they vibrate and cause the air to
vibrate too then the air gets shot out
of my mouth on its way to you this
vibration I've just made travels as a
wave but if I vibrate it differently
than it would cause the way to change if
I say moving and if I'm loud them on
microphone pops the sound wave travels
through the air unless it hits a wall
then the higher frequencies get absorbed
and the deeper ones pass through and
that's why when I'm behind a window I
found like this and if the wall is part
of the sound bounces back and you can
hear an echo the sound is captured by my
microphone it's so digitally that was
until you play this video a nice because
I'm mimicking me and now the waves are
back and going into your ear only six
more steps inside your head until you
get to hear sound is touch and
when they say that music can touch you
it literally does sound is a vibration
that fix to modern science we know the
shaking our eardrum and the drum then
shake some tiny bones and the bounce and
vibration to a liquid of the waves and
the liquid Bend some hairs of the hair
send a signal to the brain and it's only
when it falls a pattern in your head
that you can hear I never really figured
out a good way to learn that song fun
science extra mister information hi kids
I'm mister information and today I'm
gonna be giving you the gift of
knowledge now my good friend Charlie
just taught you all about sound and
hearing and hearing just so happens to
be one of the five senses which is what
I'm going to be teaching you about today
the five senses that humans have are
hearing taste smell sight and touch and
those are all of the senses that we have
some of the things that you thought you
knew about senses might be partially
incorrect depending on what your
definition of a sense is humans have at
least nine senses right nine not five
nine how'd you like that mister
information
the secret census our sense of pain
sense of temperature sense of balance
and proprioception which is knowing
where your body parts are in space
without having to look at them and now
you know the truth mr. information her
more like Miss information get it cuz
I'm calling him a woman but at the same
time he did also provide miss
information so it's like her how'd you
like that that's a very clever pun thank
you you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool